I've grown a free yeah I mean I don't
get me wrong every morning I wake up go
and do I got it do I got it yeah I'm
offered you
twenty-three-year-old with I say this
flower I told this company I go Mikoto
uh-oh hey Bert Kreischer is coming they
go we're descending 10th we're gonna
send you 10 bottles thousand-dollar
bottle you know we're saying 10 bottles
I'm at perfect my hurt will tear that
thing up dude I sit down I pour myself a
little sippy sip it's my birthday week
not a big deal
perfect week seven holy [ __ ]
drinking problem alcohol poem anyways so
I pour myself a drink Burgos no I'm not
drinking
yeah the [ __ ] wrong with you do take
October but no dude I'm off the road for
like eight weeks now it looks like so
I'm [ __ ] [ __ ] lean up and get
healthy as [ __ ] I literally do here's
the deal if I decided to go hard in this
this self-imposed state break it would
be [ __ ] dead because I there's
nothing to do I would start drinking it
for I would drink until 2:00 in the
morning if I got to put some parameter
on me because this is like what is it
idle hands yeah you you can drink are
you one of those guys if I drink one
glass of whiskey it let's say 2:00 in
the afternoon I'm done for the rest of
the day no work out I'm not working it
out I'm problem let me definitely not
drive in you can keep drinking though oh
yeah oh yeah okay and and like for me I
found I've kind of found my my
parameters if I drink when I'm on the
road doing tours if I drink after my
shows I can drink went out till whenever
bus leaves go to the next day I don't
drink during the day at all I am a
hundred percent [ __ ] perfect right
but man those morning drinking's oh
that's a problem the long day it's and
morning drinking when we pulled it in
New Orleans the day you know the day
everything broke down last week we flew
to New Orleans got the red I got it in
an eighth hit Bourbon Street
start having cocktails took a meeting
about a movie slide slide into a meeting
have more cocktails everyone's out we go
back to the bus crack another beer I'm
like I'm gonna go to bed I get a call
for my age
he's like hey we're not sure about the
no no my my my my my promoter comes in
says hey we should get on the phone to
talk that Live Nation or no no Joe boo
it's a different type of thing hi and so
they so we see on the phone and talk so
we all of a sudden I'm like about what
and they're like you know and I had had
the week before I was at Constitution
Hall Constitution Hall is pretty big
it's almost like 4,000 seats I did two
shows on the first show I didn't think
anything of it I really was like I was
like dude this coronaviruses [ __ ]
Saeki show I heard some people coughing
and way too early to be coronavirus but
I heard people coughing I thought if
this if that had been coronavirus and
there were no registered cases in DC at
the time but if it had been I would have
just spread it I was just I would have
been walked off I sat down with my guys
we poured a drink and I was like this
shit's gonna get serious very quickly
and then and then I sat down they did
the numbers or what how many people I
was doing this weekend and they're like
if you get in front of this then you
know you're not responsible at all for
this month people get infected if you
get in front of this and then just
cancel now you're gonna look like an
[ __ ] but my thing about this is like
I would like to know who exactly is
telling who are these biologists that
are telling the [ __ ] politicians and
I'd also like to know rate the what
they're saying yeah all I keep hearing
is that something some authority figure
goes we're closing everything down I'd
like a little [ __ ] explanation
because I'm still well these are not you
Eddie Bravo here me too but these are
steps so they can't just quarantine
everybody shut down for two weeks
because then the nation would be in
complete kick right so it just pains its
steps I understand all gonna get
quarantines shut down for two weeks yeah
this is that where we won't be able to
but they just they just so what did they
say yesterday's yesterday CDC says 50
plus 50 today it's 10:10 on the Friday
Trump just had to talk on the ride and
he said keep it to the group so fit of
10 don't go to bars that's a suggestion
it's a suggestion they can't mandate it
yet suggestion is gonna come down
because what's 1/2 step did you see the
picture of everyone in Nashville going a
hard as [ __ ] and the girl wrote
Nashville undefeated like goin it just
takes one person yeah
is everywhere well but you also like the
symptoms take they say you know days or
weeks to show up but also that those
people natural those are young people
okay yeah if you're young and you're
yeah my young I mean under 16 or 8 or 5
that's what they I heard okay I don't
mean interrupt no no no no we are at
that group chat you Andrew Schultz me
and Chris D'Elia and I was I was at the
airport waiting on this how fast this
ship moves waiting to do my show in New
Orleans because we're Texas everyone and
I talked to Live Nation that's more than
just I go dude
I'm headed to the airport my brother's
flying out there my opener my future
are we good he goes we're good that's at
9:00 a.m. I Drive to the airport I'm at
the airport Bert's in New Orleans I'm
like hey you're doing your show you US
as of now we'll see
and then you never like dude don't say
anything yet let me do it but I'm gonna
cancel so I go I call Justin Raj I go
dude Bert just cancelled I know we're
not doing Howard seventy million people
that he's doing but still it's 1,500
1,500 a legit sathya group of people to
bring into a group into on one place i
think i don't wanna be responsible this
are you sure we're getting us right dude
a talk line is right now you're good and
then take a sail this was crazy ticket
sales went up they go you're over the
number in Atlanta you sold out the New
Orleans it's there they come late so
it's it's over a thousand now and so I'm
like what I'm on the plane I go are you
sure we're good and I just pit myself
like this doesn't seem right man dude
that's the one the one thing that freaks
me out
Wayne we're literally everyone sitting
down born I went ding oh yeah I got a
panic sweating I mean I got to get off
she goes excuse me I go listen I'm a
stand-up comic I've shows in Atlanta New
Orleans
they're getting canceled and I was just
fine with that you need to let me off
she was let me talk to the pilot you
know the doors are closed no they let
pop off okay so I'm gonna kid my seat
let pop off that's the that's the weird
part is and not by the way this is real
inside baseball but the promoter said
just so you know we had showed we had
two shows in Huntsville and and he was
like and we meet we had still had
tickets available in the Late Show he's
like they're still selling like hotcakes
like there's like weren't like it was at
86% for the second show he's like we're
at 96% we're gonna sell that out like no
one's
worried about this so if you wanted to
show do the show I just saw another
responsibility oh right well I thought
dude it's to your point I don't mean
they're up you know did it my thing was
is like dude my bros are gonna come out
my 18 to 36 demo they're gonna come out
cuz they know they're healthy and this
ain't [ __ ] my bros are gonna come out my
fans are gonna [ __ ] come out if
somebody gets it there and it you know
it goes like that and then they go home
it goes like that
Thank You grandfather and I'm
responsible like I just can't they think
good dude look at that take a sec next
time you go into one of these theaters
look at the ushers and look how old they
are oh they're a hundred all of them up
they're a hundred I went into the
theater that night and kind of looked
around I was really [ __ ] deflated and
but then I looked at all the Oscars
hanging out and I was like oh there's
not one of them under 60 okay but here's
a chance so that's when I take my dude
Bert just scanned by the way I've so
been wrong girl Rayna me why then if we
know that the statistics are how many
people sent miss him in that bed its IFT
well they don't know where they're all
80 yeah the middle age of death okay so
they're 80 so so so plus we don't know
how many people have I understand more
but I just feel like and a lot of this
is we're learning about this yeah but I
don't understand why then the man that
is if you're an old person stay inside
is it because it's impossible to contain
it and more poby I guess it's impossible
not to catch it when you're an old
person because if you're old person in
the just the normal flu is around I need
your [ __ ] right yesterday
I go to them alright packed nobody gives
a [ __ ] I go them all outside people do
not go outside nor chose outside
Nordstrom's a little table where there's
that coffee there's a table at price
it's 14 people the Knitting old ladies
and dudes knitting they're probably all
80 to 90 yeah didn't give a [ __ ] I hope
I hope I am [ __ ] so long I hope people
in New Orleans go I'm never gonna come
see you again cuz you did that and you
overreacted I hope that's it
nobody hope I'm overreacting I hope that
I'm a lady that's a doctor a friend of
mine said he said the best-case scenario
is that we overreacted but he's he's in
UCLA and he said call me a mystery well
he's my neighbor and he said listen I'm
not gonna let my kids play with your
kids only because I'm I'm working with
this all day now we're starting to see
cases and I think
responsible for me too because the kids
can carry it and I said that's fine and
we hope for the best expect the worst
but he sent me an article he said no he
said this that what we want to do this
because it will be best case scenarios
that we overreacted that's a good thing
that's that's me is overreact like like
my kids are yeah yeah I'm not going out
not going out for st. Patty's Day so my
demos point four percent twenty twenty
to thirty nine this and by the way point
for me yeah but that's also like
worldwide and here's the other thing
there's so many because with the because
there's outliers in China because like
80% of the people smoke and charge but
also but also China lies right who knows
what the [ __ ] you how many people died
there they coverage it but the other
China but anyways but the other terrible
food anyways but the other thing is is
they can't tell only rich people can
test for it it's only the rich again
tested there's so many more cases than
we know if yeah but how many we know how
many people died 50 yeah maybe a little
more let's say let's say 200 but there's
so many people with it I thought I had
it three weeks ago we went to the
Rangers game in Texas or New York in New
York we went to the Knicks game in the
Rangers game right so we're at the
Rangers game and they come up and
they're like hey man we won't throw you
on the jumbotron Wow we'd love for you
to kill a beer well they did it at the
Knicks game and they're like can we have
you kill a beer and I was like yeah of
course rip my shirt off kill a beer up
on the jumbotron yeah Madison Square
Garden goes nuts right yeah I don't even
know who I am I'm just some dude rip the
shirt off kill his beer hey st. Patty's
Day on Netflix like I'm all in it go to
the name range again the next day
they're like come on no shirts coming
off kill a beer and I had been like I've
been instructed not to take my shirt off
so did we no no so I tell them I go I'm
not taking my shirt off and we're at a
hockey match it's cold I go bond kill a
beer and then I great we're coming in
three I go I don't have a beer and then
I get one and so my [ __ ] Dave goes
everyone pour some beer in here's oh oh
well that's not
okay guys there's a crowd of ours going
around I think I'll be sharing beers and
then they go we're coming either they
passed me this beer I'm like I just got
Corona you did a schooi yeah you did in
New York Zoey and so so I was dude I in
my brain I start [ __ ] I wake up the
next and I go oh I'm getting it I'm
definitely getting it but it's been now
two weeks I've never I've never had a
symptom I don't have a coffee and I ran
five miles this morning yeah yeah yeah
yeah watch your tongue Oh what's gonna
happen what are you gonna do use some of
that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]